this is time to go did you wear your
bike shorts you did not tell me you are
weirdos are they in your lock I did I
did say to Willie he's our next break
bike shorts look at you look how old
back row I don't shake the back rows
suck it back row yeah look at the room
first time I've been in new I what go
roomy it is Wow
I have to say yeah I did say I was gonna
do my shoes Mina said he said I do I'll
wear my bike shorts if you wear yours I
know but you didn't respond to that
given you look good you look really in
shape thank you maybe too good like I
heard you saying I have you lost your
funny sometimes when you get a little
thinner and better shape I was listening
from one actor one comedian to another
yeah Jonah Hill was on and he lost all
of that weight and I said I think do
people look at you differently
you're not as funny to some people
because you look better by pathetically
hypothetically speaking yes it took a
turn quickly and then it ended right yes
it did yeah sit back since there will so
I'll choose my words carefully how much
weight did you jump I think I've dropped
like 15 now you look great yeah yeah you
went on the biking trip we're on the
biking trip you sent the picture of you
from behind the bike shorts on you guys
it's better from the rear it's I think
is that what way it's better from the
back better from the back yeah yeah yeah
can you send some pictures to her and I
said you really you look like you uh you
purposely went out to lose some weight
here yeah I was legitimately training
but this is it was writing a movie role
no life there's just five guys going on
it going on a trip now do you have to
put on weight to go back
into movies I've got ya now now I've got
a gain i got a gain the 15 plus an extra
15 for what I call it additional funny
15 oh yeah this is seller 50 killer 15
so but then you're around Mark Wahlberg
in this movie that's right so when
you're when you're doing with press with
mark because mark has got yo yeah
everything's fitted yeah very great very
tight which have you noticed that all
men's clothes are now fitted there's
there's not the regular cut anymore yeah
really bums me out
speaking of biking we're okay yeah this
is actually a normal cut but but
Wahlberg's jacked what works typically
Jack did you feel like you needed to
sort of be well when when we started
doing per se I thought I better bring my
my a-game because we're we're often
sitting next to each other but during
the filming of the movie no I don't have
to worry about being jacked at all you
have Mel Gibson and John lists I just
like saying being Jack so that's Fritz
oh yeah yeah
we're glad to have you it's great to be
here yeah and I said some nice things I
don't know if you heard the nice thing
that was that was actually one of my
favorite days of doing anything coming
on as Ron Burgundy indulging me by
letting me stand on the street corner
with because I loved that shot you guys
know do you want occasion I know but you
know I was watching one time weren't
there two guys with a cardboard sign
that said like hey Dan what's up one day
and people stand out there with signs
yeah but the fact that you said I want
to stand out there with doughnuts in a
40 right and that you gave in so much
that it was it was the drive over it was
but you got beer at 8:00 in the morning
as Ron Burgundy and I loved the footage
of when I left the crowd and that I
stood up and gave the crowd a fist for
no reason like our breath
you were Mel Gibson in brave heart I've
done it yeah what's the role that you
look back on now and you go I don't know
how I did that
I don't know how I pulled that off well
there is a movie that uh that very few
people have seen called Casa de mi padre
which is in have you seen well have you
seen a Polly oka I assume you're making
that up
No look it up McLovin I've seen it I
didn't understand all the word it's
entirely in Spanish yeah it's myself in
Diego Luna I wanted to do a movie which
I did yeah yeah and it's kind of like
Spanish soap opera meets a bad kind of
narcotraffic on a Mexican I just saw the
posters I did right I didn't see the
movie so I did the entire movie in
Spanish with English subtitles it's it's
so my best work give me a little taste
there um like I'm trying to remember
wait you forgot your span yeah totally
there was a song I saying to it'll come
back by the way and I did bring this up
when I die if I die before you do would
you sing dust in the wind at my funeral
is that asking too I mean it we're live
now it's on well how much do I get paid
I'm gonna give you whatever you make
from the door do cuz there's a Greg do I
get per diem do I get flown out oh wow
where I can get buried in LA well then
no problem oh yeah we'll come back we'll
Farrell's got a new movie out I think
that's a yes that you'll sing dust in
the wind I pretty
yeah I'll sing so it's going to remember
my Spanish I work on that we have a
little bit of time is called a
commercial break coming up here Will
Ferrell great shape is he still as funny
as he once was find out my co-host is
Will Ferrell daddy's home two hits
theaters on Friday that's Mark Wahlberg
and Will Ferrell Brad and dusty are back
together again John Lithgow and Mel
Gibson will be they play the dads in
this movie they play our dads they're
your dance yeah yeah Thursday who would
you like to have in real
is your dad between those two well I
mean John and I got very close we we
kiss in the movie a lot because we're
very but that wasn't scripted that was
not scripted ever and we just happened
to capture it on film we did bring this
up pre-show where we went back and
looked at some of your movies and of
course the tighty-whities that you have
and and Paulie asked if any of us still
have tighty-whitey underwear now one
person can you guess the one person who
still has tighty whitey underwear
well of my group the Dennett McLovin
nope Seton No Oh fritzy now he normally
doesn't wear underwear is that stated
that's on the record once in awhile I'll
do the underwear it's gotta be a special
occasion huh but what is funny okay
nudity or tighty whities well I mean you
know nudity is it's easy right it's it's
the obvious choice
I think yeah you know I'm mangled you
know tighty-whitey
is is funnier in a way yeah but they
can't be too like it can't be too clean
nice that's what I mean like the
presentation exactly like roughened
ruffled a rumpled rumpled something like
that or somewhere yeah yeah if you'd
like to get in touch with a program not
that we'll be able to answer your phone
calls but I'm contracted by the way the
phones are out eight seven seven three
DP show email under stevia dan Patrick
calm wait okay go ahead what I've got to
get you guys were talking about Hall of
Fame yeah Baseball Hall of Fame and my
manager Jimmy has implored me to bring
up to bring up Veda Pinson into the
discussion Cincinnati Reds way to pinch
Nevada Penson and he challenges you guys
to compare Willie McCovey and vada pence
ins rook
he was the Rookie of the Year of McCovey
in 59 okay compare the numbers it's
shocking that vada Penson was not Rookie
of the Year or that he is in the Hall of
Fame I think if you look at Veda Pinson
you don't realize how many hit
he had I thought he has shy of 3,000 I
think he had 2020 128 82 28 played for
18 seasons you know yeah Paulie
yeah I got him at twenty seven fifty
seven hits in 18 years that's pretty
good it's pretty good
but he played before the Big Red Machine
so he lost out on all go to ride all
that yeah prestige yeah winning because
then they brought in say Sarge Iran mo
as their centerfielder but beta Pinson
was a great player to a defense and
great player yeah he was did you go to
the dance I will dedicate my tendon to
the Hall of Fame if they need it you
would we should Tommy John be in the
Hall of Fame for just Tommy Jones just
because of the surgery yes sure just a
little just a little they should have
but he won 288 games yeah I kiddin
that's great for Lawson ah and the
tendon and the tendon they should have a
section of the Hall of Fame for just
advanced medical procedures based on the
players who had them regardless of their
stats who's gonna go in for steroids
though if somebody's got to say well
that's a whole nother way right yes it
is it's a larger wing it's a larger wing
yep but what do you think of my idea
that you have certain floors right in
the Hall of Fame that Babe Ruth's in the
penthouse and Willie Mays and Hank Aaron
and you might in the basement but you're
in right why not why not because I think
what happened sometimes as you go well
Alan Trammell you can't put him in there
with Hank Aaron well no we're not saying
that I'm not saying on the same low he's
on yeah he's on the second piece in yeah
yeah he might be first first floor yeah
did you did you have a favorite baseball
player growing up I did love Steve
Garvey hate him I've never met Steve I
love Don Baylor being an Angels fan
mm-hmm I got to meet Don OC you were an
angel fans angel I was both I mean the
Dodgers were always a little better so
huge rants Mullenix fan horse you were
huge of course you were somebody has to
be and you were that guy did you have
posters on your wall no I don't think so
I think I had one Dodger penat but you
were you wanted to be a sports I want to
be soars it I had the penet from I don't
know what year was the Dodgers had Ron
Cey Dusty Baker Steve Garvey
and Davey Lopes no they therefore
players who hit 30 Reggie Smith Reggie
Smith yeah I had that pin it yeah that's
some plastic batting helmets you know
small clock but I didn't have huge
posters is there something in your
childhood you want to tell me about like
you didn't really have an enjoyable I
didn't have walls to my tent
okay lives in a coal mine 10 yeah okay
try some tacking a poster wall of a 10
it shreds the tent you can't do it I'm
sorry to bring up something sensitive
there but there had to be a reason why
you didn't have that Dan you did can you
cry my soul cry on cue I can fake cry on
cue yeah like okay yeah like right now
oh right now yeah we're like what would
you think about if you're gonna fake cry
I mean you don't have to do it I mean De
Niro did it why you came in yeah Joanie
Hill did it too yeah he cried it my
questions alright I can do this like
that thing are you constipated like
that's a that's it
well you're killing it but that's more
comedy crying but that's right when who
died you gave oh yeah that but that felt
real that felt I know the audience felt
that yeah yeah yeah favorite movie
growing up favorite movie growing up
impactful impactful I would say Animal
House very impactful now who was your
guy in Animal House John Belushi oh yeah
did you ever meet Balu I loved Volusia I
love the you know the stairway scene
with the guy my love is like a cherry
and then he takes the acoustic guitar
bishop was he the guy I
think he was an actual musician and he's
blue she pauses and then smash but I
also had with thee for some reason I
thought in that scene they didn't tell
him that Belushi was going to do that
talk yeah yeah
they must have because you can tell it's
a breakaway guitar in the scene oh yeah
I'm sorry okay mr. Hollywood
okay look I'm turning this on you got me
yeah yeah yeah
stuntman do you have a stunt double how
often do you ever sneak double I have a
fantastic stunt double but in the first
movie there were a lot of yeah you're on
the roof and there's a lot of there's
there are a lot of comedic physical
comedy and this one as well in which Tod
my stunt double did a lot of fantastic
work in fact Todd looks pretty much like
me from you can shoot him from the front
and for far away and you can't tell and
I remember we were shooting in fact with
Mark the first movie was shot the other
guys yeah who's shooting downtown and
there were some guys it was near NYU and
there was some some guys in their dorm
room saying we'll come on up and have a
beer with us I was like you got it I'll
be up in five Todd was dressed just like
they'd see me in my time go I go which
one they're like 5d so he walks up I
didn't go with him he came back he's
like ah they were so bummed that he rang
the doorbell he walks in they're like
yeah no way he's here
they sat him down on the couch he popped
a beer for him they started drinking the
beer with him that just slowly looked at
him you're not will he's like yeah I
know they sent me up there
all right can you okay yeah if you don't
mind we really want to will it slide
left and told me the whole story yeah
daddy's home to in theaters Friday at a
theater near you can you stay I'm gonna
ask you about the World Series than the
Dodgers and did you go and all that
stuff okay
can you stay are you sure yeah what I
got no but that didn't sound cool do you
have to go no I'm good
you sure I'm great okay so 11:30 hard
out huh heard that hard out
taillights 11:28 let's call 11 28 wheels
up middle 728 11 to 8 and I got a sports
figure that I think you resemble or he
resembles you I want to bring your
attention yeah it's called a tease great
so you don't say anything now and then
we go I want to blurt it out so I so
badly want talking about Roethlisberger
yes really
why don't you just guessed I know yes
what you said I don't you know about a
tease like Aaron the more you I was
gonna say nothing you go do you have any
idea well you could have said yes you
didn't have to say who it was
have you ever just excited to be happy
yeah I'm excited
yeah you got your bike shorts on bike
shorts on I appreciate that
have you ever been told you look like
Ben Roethlisberger on occasion okay yeah
I'm trying to think of other athletes
now let's take a break okay come back
ruined it will continue with Will
Ferrell after this in the Dan Patrick
show the Ferrell is back in studio
staying in studio he's been in our LA
studio the home mancave and here in New
York yes Paula first ever Dan Patrick
show guest look here live and all three
swell well done they call it the treble
right at three three three we're gonna
get a plaque now daddy's home to hits
theaters this Friday at a theater near
you with dusty Mark Wahlberg and Brad
Will Ferrell they joined forces to
provide their kids the perfect Christmas
and Dusty's school Nestle you got your
dad Mel Gibson you're not your dad
there's John Lithgow is your dad and Mel
Gibson is Mark Wahlberg's dad exactly
yes
do you want to tell us about the movie
and it's you know it's a great comedy
Christmas comedy for the family as well
as sophisticated humor for the adults
okay so I said before the break and then
you ruin the tease that have you ever
been told that you look like right I
jumped the gun yeah Ben Roethlisberger
anybody else trying to think cuz I don't
have anybody else oh you don't know no
no I jump on Karate Kid the guy ran the
Cobra Kai someone just sent in they say
did your hair now looks like the guys
over yeah yeah okay that's a great scene
though that was a very yep love that
movie absolutely yeah that's it that's
all okay I was also wondering this and I
don't know why I thought of this but I
thought of this last night how you
discipline your kids how are your boys
13 we have a 13 year old a 10 year old
and a 7 okay now they know what you do
for a living right and are you funny at
home therefore does it make it hard for
you to discipline your kids you know
they don't they're tough they're tough
critics yeah yeah they don't think did
like your movies they one of them the
ten-year-old just recently snuck in saw
stepbrothers yeah did he talk about mom
doesn't know the scene where you know
his mom doesn't you watch her listen to
the show we're safe when you rub on the
drums said yeah that was come up the
chest it was you thought that was the
greatest thing I did to which it's just
like I could tell he's looking at me
like I thought I knew you
I don't even I'm even cracked the
surface but could he do it at home it
would you punish him if he did it at
home I don't think I would you wouldn't
yeah I would I mean I think it's it's on
it's gonna be unpleasant for him it's
not gonna feel yeah yeah yeah yeah but
can you discipline your kids and
actually be mean I'm like appraisingly
Stern's
give me an idea
I'm the ten-year-old and I just did
something like I rub my testicles on a
drum kit okay if you're not like come on
we need to go to bed let's go
come on let's go does that work
let's go I'm tired okay but see I'm
lying yeah yeah I'm laughing they're not
laughing I we still have fun with the
was it the SNL audition the roof they
get off the shed yeah get off the [ __ ]
yeah oh my god get off the shed yeah
it's a whole bed which the fam I love
most about that bit you're auditioning
I'm audition okay from a creative
standpoint I love the fact that what why
is this shed so important and what is it
what is this shed is it just a little
gardening shed yeah yeah goes ballistic
okay so recreate the scene here right
who's watching you audition for Sarah I
live it is a sketch I'd done at The
Groundlings to great success where I'm a
suburban dad at a barbecue having you
know banal you know small talk yeah and
occasionally you hear me go hey gay be a
buddy and get off the shed anyway I've
been golfing with Pete Henderson I
understand he's a for handicap can you
believe it hey buddy
get off the shed okay anyway you going
to the PTA meeting yeah I think I'll see
you there hey get off the shed so I tell
you said to but anyway it keeps if you
don't get out the shed and then it just
keeps going back and forth now I'm doing
this to an empty studio there's no one
here that a camera guy and a boom guy
and Lauren Michaels is in the shadows
can you hear him laughing no no I'm in a
void I'm just doing that thinking it's
so good I don't
I don't wonder that I hope this works
but I became known from the auditions as
they get off the shed guy yes Molly well
is that where ma the meatloaf came from
and wedding crashers is that offshoot of
that I don't know that not necessarily
maybe subconsciously but you know
meatloaf will never be mentioned again
to anyone yeah range if my wife says I'm
making meatloaf I yell atop my lawn
which was so weird because in that scene
it's just Owen and I and I just started
thinking it was so funny that my mom is
back there so I just started screaming
mom or more meatloaf I don't know we
just messing around that day but somehow
that sticks in the so it's so good it's
so good so you never know a weirdest
moment on Saturday on 11:28 by the way I
know we're very precise around here does
anybody tell you what who tells you what
to do in terms of in life yeah me the
wife sometimes let's go maybe okay let's
not do that I would really like to do
this so I take my cues that way but
we're I never get shut out it out ya
know you don't ya okay the most part so
strangest moment on Saturday Night Live
strangest moment like the one that
you'll tell your grandkids if you can
tell your grandkids well I mean one of
the stranger moments was getting to meet
George Bush when he was then governor
George Bush campaigning and they made a
huge deal about the fact that he really
wants to meet you he's such a fan of
your impersonation of him they throw us
into this room and I can tell he has no
idea and I at what point pleased to meet
you and I go yeah so are you doing him
no I'm just a civilian will and then I
can tell you just like why am i shaking
your hand
and then I think it slowly clicked like
oh wait you're the guy yeah so that was
a weird one after they made such a big
deal that he was dying to meet you it's
weird for you it was yeah yeah probably
not for him yeah maybe not maybe I mean
he's meeting a thousand people and but I
just like why did you why did you do
that why did you know I was a little mad
at our show yeah yeah do you throw
temper - what would make you be a diva
you ever had one oh I don't think I've
ever had a diva moment no no no no every
day is a great day calm cool and
collected yeah yeah just an all-around
great guy all-around guy yeah where you
want ready to go where you all ready to
go now
yeah it's 11:30 uh-oh
55 second oh you 11:31 no no I gotta go
okay all right all right so where you
going by the way okay he's uh Will
Ferrell the movies daddy daddy's home -
yeah it's in theaters Friday
check out those bike shorts thanks guys
leaving nothing to the imagination with
those bike shorts there so Mark Wahlberg
take a break Will Ferrell's left the
building for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app